ah the West mythical home of Roadrunner
John Wayne and families and wagons
heading for a fresh start on the rugged
frontier wide open sky and these big red
rock formations make up its
stereotypical backdrop the one in movies
and cartoons well there's got to be a
phone or a gas station around here
somewhere honey
but when you look at a bunch of those
movies back-to-back you start to notice
something this image of the West kind of
looks the same whenever we see it and
that's because this specific group of
formations is unique to one place
Monument Valley so how did this one area
become a symbol of the American West
[Music]
Monument Valley is on the Arizona Utah
border inside the Navajo Nation
reservation its towering red sandstone
formations called buttes rise hundreds
of feet above the desert floor for
centuries only Native Americans
specifically the Paiute and Navajo
occupied this remote landscape fielding
conflicts with the US government
non-indigenous people began to visit in
the early 20th century and in the early
1920s Colorado sheep trader Harry
Golding and his wife Leona set up a
trading post on the Utah side of
Monument Valley which at the time was
just outside of the Navajo reservation
in the 1930s this area was hit hard by
droughts the Great Depression and a
forced reduction of livestock by the US
government which slashed a vital source
of income
Goldin tried for years to draw attention
to Monument Valley stunning landscape
thinking tourism could help boost the
local economy but according to Golding
the area's big break didn't come until
1938 when he brought photos of Monument
Valley to Hollywood
stagecoach directed by John Ford and
shot primarily on location in Monument
Valley revolutionized the Western
elevating the genre from the low-budget
pulp reputation it had developed in the
1930s what's known as a b-movie into one
of Hollywood's most popular genres for
the next 20 years who's also the
breakout role for American icon John
Wayne who until this point had spent
years starring in B westerns like 1933
riders of destiny
stagecoach mainstream the Western and
it's here that audiences began to
associate Monument Valley with the
mythic American West
an epic isolated landscape full of
potential the kind of place where
outlaws and outcasts could find a fresh
start following Ford's lead other
filmmakers began using Monument Valley
as their Western backdrops including
Ford himself seven more times most
notably in the searchers often regarded
as the ultimate Western the movie takes
place in Texas but that didn't matter
by then Monument Valley was a cliche and
cliches are useful for storytelling they
signal to the audience what kind of
story this is or set a familiar tone and
advertising those buttes are so
ingrained in pop culture that they can
be used as shorthand for stories of
western adventure which might be why the
Coen brothers chose it as the backdrop
for the opening scene of The Ballad of
Buster Scruggs their 2018 homage and
parody of the genre song never fails to
ease my mind out here in the West where
the distances are great and a scenery
Menaka when the film company that made
stagecoach wrapped production and left
Monument Valley in late 1938 it had paid
Navajo locals somewhere around $50,000
hundreds had worked as crew members and
extras though they played the roles of
Apache bad guys
according to reports at the time that
money was enough to get them to the
winter and as Monument Valley's
reputation grew Goulding's planned to
bring in tourism started working the
Monument Valley Navajo tribal park now
sees around 350 thousand visitors each
year tourists can visit the Trading Post
and go on Navajo led tours of the famous
buttes and they get there by taking this
road US Highway 163 you've probably seen
it before
it's where Forrest Gump ended his famous
run across America Alabama Alabama is in
the other direction but that doesn't
matter this backdrop could be anywhere
in the West
[Music]
you